pour me ramener en sécurité
après un accident de voiture qui aurait pu me tuer.
Tout cela m'a, bien sûr, vraiment bouleversée
mais m'a aussi laissée avec ce besoin brûlant, ce tiraillement
de comprendre pourquoi il l'a fait,
quelles forces en lui l'ont poussé à faire le choix
auquel je dois la vie,
à risquer sa propre vie pour sauver celle d'une étrangère ?
Dit autrement, quelles sont les causes de sa capacité à l'altruisme,
à lui ou à n'importe qui d'autre ?
Laissez-moi vous dire ce qu'il s'est passé.
Cette nuit-là, j'avais 19 ans,
je rentrais chez moi à Tacoma,
sur l'Interstate 5,
quand un petit chien est passé devant ma voiture.
J'ai fait exactement ce qu'il ne faut pas faire,
j'ai fait une embardée pour l'éviter.
J'ai découvert pourquoi il ne faut pas faire cela.
J'ai quand même heurté le chien
et la voiture est partie en queue de poisson,
puis en vrille sur l'autoroute
jusqu'à ce que, finalement, je finisse sur la voie de gauche de l'autoroute,
faisant face au trafic entrant,
et là, le moteur a lâché.
A ce moment-là, j'étais sûre que j'allais aussi mourir
mais ça n'a pas été le cas
grâce aux actes de cet homme courageux
qui doit avoir décidé
en une fraction de seconde, en voyant ma voiture immobilisée,
de s'arrêter et de courir, traverser quatre voies d'autoroute
dans le noir
pour me sauver la vie.
Puis, après avoir redémarré ma voiture,
m'avoir amenée en sécurité et s'être assuré que j'allais bien,
il est reparti.
Il ne m'a jamais dit son nom
et je suis presque certaine d'avoir oublié de le remercier.
Avant d'aller plus loin,
j'aimerais prendre un instant
pour marquer une pause et remercier cet étranger.
(Applaudissements)
Je vous dis tout cela
car les événements de cette nuit
ont, à un certain degré, changé le cours de ma vie.
Je suis devenue chercheuse en psychologie,
j'ai dédié mon travail à la compréhension de la capacité des humains
à s'intéresser aux autres.
D'où cela vient-il ? Comment ça se développe ?
Quelles en sont les formes extrêmes ?
Ces questions sont importantes à la compréhension
des aspects fondamentaux de la nature sociale humaine.
Beaucoup de gens,
cela va des philosophes aux économistes et aux gens ordinaires,
croient que la nature humaine est foncièrement égoïste,
que nous ne sommes motivés que par notre propre bien-être.
Mais si cela est vrai, pourquoi certains, comme l'étranger m'ayant sauvée,
font-ils des choses désintéressées, comme aider des gens
en prenant des risques énormes ?
Répondre à cette question
requiert d'explorer les racines d'actes d'altruisme extraordinaires
et ce qui pourrait faire que les gens agissant ainsi
soient différents des autres.
Jusqu'à récemment, très peu de travail avait été fait à ce sujet.
Les actions de l'homme m'ayant sauvée
répondent à la définition la plus stricte de l'altruisme
qui est un comportement volontaire et coûteux
motivé par le désir d'aider un autre individu.
C'est un acte désintéressé destiné uniquement à aider l'autre.
Comment est-il possible d'expliquer une telle action ?
Une réponse est, bien sûr, la compassion,
qui est un moteur clé de l'altruisme.
Mais, alors, la question devient :
pourquoi certains semblent-ils en avoir plus que d'autres ?
La réponse pourrait être que le cerveau des personnes très altruistes
est fondamentalement différent.
Mais pour comprendre comment,
je suis partie de l'autre extrémité :
les psychopathes.
Une approche pour comprendre les aspects de la nature humaine,
comme le désir d'aider les autres,
est d'étudier les gens chez qui ce désir est absent
et les psychopathes sont exactement cela.
La psychopathie est un trouble du développement
ayant des origines génétiques fortes
et résultant en une personnalité froide et insensible,
une tendance à adopter des comportements antisociaux, voire très violents.
Mes collègues du National Institute of Mental Health et moi
avons conduit la première recherche en imagerie cérébrale
sur des adolescents psychopathes.
Nos découvertes et celles de recherches plus récentes
ont montré que les gens psychopathiques
présentent, généralement, trois caractéristiques.
Un, bien qu'en général ils ne soient pas insensibles aux émotions des autres,
ils sont insensibles aux signaux de détresse des autres.
En particulier,
ils ont du mal à reconnaître des expressions faciales de peur
comme celle-ci.
Les expressions de peur communiquent
un besoin urgent, une détresse émotionnelle
et elles provoquent de la compassion, un désir d'aider
chez ceux qui les voient.
Il est logique que les gens qui manquent de compassion
soient aussi insensibles à ces signaux.
La partie du cerveau
la plus importante pour reconnaître les expressions de peur
s'appelle l'amygdale.
Il y a quelques rares cas de gens n'ayant pas du tout d'amygdale
et ils ont de fortes déficiences pour reconnaître les expressions de peur.
Alors que les adultes et enfants sains
montrent en général des pics d'activité de l'amygdale
en voyant des expressions de peur,
les amygdales des psychopathes réagissent peu à ces expressions.
Parfois, elles ne réagissent pas,
ce qui expliquerait leur difficulté à détecter ces signaux.
Les amygdales des psychopathes sont plus petites que la moyenne
de 18% à 20%.
Toutes ces découvertes sont fiables, robustes
et très intéressantes.
Mais mon intérêt principal
n'est pas de comprendre pourquoi les gens ne s'intéressent pas aux autres
mais pourquoi ils s'y intéressent.
La vraie question est :
un altruisme extraordinaire,
qui est l'exact opposé de la psychopathie,
en termes de compassion et de désir d'aider les autres,
pourrait-il émerger d'un cerveau qui est l'opposé de celui d'un psychopathe ?
Un genre de cerveau anti-psychopathique,
plus capable de reconnaître les peurs des gens,
une amygdale plus réactive à cette expression,
voire plus grande que la moyenne ?
Comme mes recherches l'ont montré,
ces trois choses sont vraies.
Nous l'avons découvert
en testant une population de gens vraiment altruistes.
Ce sont des gens qui ont donné un de leurs propres reins
à un parfait inconnu.
Ils se sont portés volontaires pour subir une opération majeure
afin qu'un de leurs reins parfaitement sain soit enlevé
et transplanté à un inconnu très malade
qu'ils ne rencontreront jamais.
On demande souvent : « Pourquoi quelqu'un ferait-il cela ? »
La réponse pourrait être
que le cerveau de ces gens très altruistes
a des caractéristiques particulières.
Ils reconnaissent mieux la peur des autres.
Ils détectent mieux quand quelqu'un est en détresse.
Cela peut être dû, en partie,
à la réactivité accrue de leur amygdale face à ces expressions.
C'est la même partie du cerveau qui, comme on l'a découvert,
était en sous-activité chez les psychopathes.
Pour finir, leur amygdale est plus grande que la moyenne
d'environ 8%.
Réunies, ces données suggèrent
l'existence d'une continuité de l'intérêt pour les autres dans le monde
qui est ancrée, d'un côté, par des gens très psychopathiques
et, d'un autre côté, par des gens très compatissants,
poussés à des actes d'altruisme extrême.
Je devrais rajouter que ce qui rend les gens très altruistes si différents
n'est pas qu'ils sont plus compatissants que la moyenne.
Ils le sont,
mais le plus inhabituel chez eux
est qu'ils sont compatissants et altruistes
non seulement envers les gens de leur cercle le plus proche
d'amis et de membres de la famille.
Avoir de la compassion pour ceux que vous aimez, que vous reconnaissez
n'est pas extraordinaire.
La compassion des vrais altruistes s'étend au-delà de ce cercle,
au-delà de leur cercle de connaissances,
jusqu'à ceux qui sont complètement hors de leur cercle social,
de parfaits inconnus,
comme l'homme qui m'a sauvée.
J'ai eu l'opportunité de demander aux donneurs de rein altruistes
comment ils parvenaient à générer un si grand cercle de compassion
pour qu'ils soient prêts à donner leur rein à un parfait étranger.
J'ai découvert qu'il leur est très difficile de répondre.
Je leur dis : « Comment se fait-il que vous soyez prêt à faire cela
alors que tant d'autres ne le veulent pas ?
Vous êtes parmi les moins de 2 000 Américains
qui ont donné un rein à un étranger.
Qu'est-ce qui vous rend si spécial ? »
Que disent-ils ?
Ils disent : « Rien.
Je ne suis en rien spécial.
Je suis comme tout le monde. »
Et je pense que cette réponse est très révélatrice
car elle suggère que les cercles des altruistes ne ressemblent pas à ceci
mais plutôt à ceci.
Ils n'ont pas de centre.
Ces altruistes ne se voient vraiment pas
comme étant le centre de quoique ce soit,
comme étant meilleur ou plus important qu'un autre.
En demandant à une altruiste pourquoi le don de son rein avait du sens,
elle a dit : « Car il n'est pas question de moi. »
Un autre a dit :
« Je ne suis pas différent ni unique.
Votre étude va montrer que je suis exactement comme vous. »
Je pense que la meilleure description à cette incroyable absence de nombrilisme
est l'humilité,
qui est une qualité qui, selon les mots de Saint Augustin,
fait des hommes des anges.
Pourquoi ?
Car si votre cercle n'a pas de centre,
il ne peut y avoir de cercles intérieurs, extérieurs,
personne ne mérite plus ou moins votre attention, votre compassion qu'un autre.
A mon avis, c'est la vraie distinction entre les altruistes extraordinaires
et les personnes ordinaires.
Je pense aussi que c'est un point de vue sur le monde atteignable par beaucoup
voire par la majorité des gens.
Je le crois car, à un niveau sociétal,
les expansions d'altruisme, de compassion arrivent partout.
Le psychologue Steven Pinker et d'autres ont montré
que, partout dans le monde, les gens acceptent de moins en moins
la souffrance de cercles de plus en plus larges,
ce qui a mené au déclin de tous genres de cruautés et violences,
que ce soit envers les animaux, la violence domestique, la peine capitale.
Cela a mené à une augmentation de tous genres d'altruisme.
Il y a une centaine d'années, les gens auraient trouvé ridicule
qu'il soit normal aujourd'hui
que les gens donnent du sang ou de la moelle osseuse
à de parfaits inconnus.
Est-il possible que, dans cent ans,
les gens pensent que donner un rein à un inconnu
soit aussi normal et ordinaire
que de donner du sang ou de la moelle osseuse aujourd'hui ?
Peut-être.
Qu'est-ce qui est à l'origine de ces changements formidables ?
Il semble que ce soit en partie
des augmentations de la richesse et du niveau de vie.
Quand les sociétés deviennent plus riches,
les gens semblent diriger leur attention vers l'extérieur
et il en résulte des augmentations de l'altruisme envers les inconnus,
du bénévolat aux dons aux œuvres de charité, et même les dons de reins.
Mais tous ces changements produisent aussi
un résultat étrange et paradoxal
qui est que, alors que le monde devient meilleur et plus humain,
ce qui est le cas,
la perception courante est que le monde empire,
devient plus cruel, ce qui est faux.
Et je ne comprends pas pourquoi,
mais peut-être que nous en savons beaucoup plus
sur la souffrance des inconnus dans des lieux lointains
et que nous nous intéressons beaucoup plus
à la souffrance de ces inconnus lointains.
Ce qui est clair est que les changements observés montrent
que les origines de l'altruisme et de la compassion
sont autant dans la nature humaine que la cruauté et la violence,
peut-être même plus,
et, bien que certains semblent être intrinsèquement plus sensibles
aux souffrances d'autres gens lointains,
je crois vraiment que la capacité à nous extraire
du centre du cercle
et à étendre notre cercle de compassion afin d'y inclure mêmes des inconnus
est à la portée de presque tout le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)